the guy who builds electric cars and is
trying to go to mars is now officially a
social media mogul it wasn't easy
twitter's board activated what's known
as a poison pill a way of trying to stop
someone from acquiring the company by
flooding the market with shares making a
buyout more expensive however the board
warmed up to the idea of a takeover
after he disclosed he secured 46.5
billion in financing according to the
securities and exchange commission
filing musk said he put in 21 billion in
equity financing while banks including
morgan stanley and other firms around
the world lined up another 25 and a half
billion in various forms of debt and
margin loan financing this is greater
than is offered to buy twitter at 54.20
a share totaling approximately 44
billion which he said was his best and
final offer and if it didn't work out he
said he'd sell the nine percent of stock
he currently owns and walk away well
twitter's board ended up accepting his
original offer of 44 billion the board
then nixed the poison pill had they kept
it in place it could have reinforced
musk's argument that the board isn't
looking out for the interest of
shareholders the board unanimously
approved the sale twitter's independent
board chair said the twitter board
conducted a thoughtful and comprehensive
process to assess elon's proposal with a
deliberate focus on value certainty and
financing the proposed transaction will
deliver a substantial cash premium and
we believe it is the best path forward
for twitter's stockholders
musk reportedly met with some
shareholders in the hopes they could
pressure the company and sway their
decision he had hinted that he was even
willing to circumvent the board by
appealing to shareholders to sell their
stock directly to him known as a tender
offer he alluded to the strategy
tweeting blank is the knight potentially
in reference to f scott fitzgerald's
novel tender is the night a couple of
days before that he tweeted at the
lyrics love me tender from elvis
presley's hit
so how will twitter differ now that musk
is at the helm he's flirted with several
changes from converting its san
francisco headquarters into a homeless
shelter adding an edit button or amusing
about changing the bird logo to a doge
above all else musk says he wants
twitter to become a public square for
free speech in his original sec filing
stating his desire to buy the social app
musk said twitter has potential to be
the platform for free speech around the
globe but doesn't feel it is in its
current state saying i now realize the
company will neither thrive nor serve
the societal imperative in his current
form some have speculated that he'd
reinstate donald trump's twitter account
which was shut down permanently over his
tweets surrounding the 2021 capitol
riots he apparently mused about buying
twitter in march according to the head
of the christian satire site the babylon
b after the b got its twitter account
suspended for naming transgender
official dr rachel levine as the man of
the year after usa today named dr levine
one of its women of the year
conservatives have long accused the
platform of discriminating against them
in 2020 twitter blocked users from
sharing a new york post article that was
critical of hunter biden the son of then
presidential candidate joe biden twitter
said the post violated its hacked
materials policy then twitter ceo jack
dorsey later said it was wrong to block
the story
crucial to musk's vision is open
sourcing twitter's algorithm that
decides which tweets get promoted or
demoted in other words have it available
for people to see and improve upon that
way he says there won't be any
manipulation behind the scenes to push
certain tweets in front of more eyeballs
while de-emphasizing others musk views
free speech as essential to a democracy
and worries that there is too much
censorship during a ted talk in april he
said speech should be as free as
possible and that he'd err on the side
of not removing controversial posts he
feels the ideal policy for a social app
is when the most extreme ten percent on
the left and the right are equally
unhappy but content moderation is very
very difficult big tech companies spend
billions of dollars reviewing millions
of uploads each day former reddit ceo
yeshuan wong warned musk is in for a
world of pain arguing in a thread that
the tesla ceo doesn't fully understand
the difficulty of content moderation and
protecting free speech online he
continued elon is not going to fix some
problems i'm absolutely sure of this he
has no idea what he's in for wong argues
that big platforms like twitter have no
choice but to censor because the web has
grown so big that anyone can post
anything anywhere at any time so it has
to be moderated in some way he ended his
long thread by concluding musk buying
twitter will hurt all of humanity by
distracting him from his mission at
spacex and tesla because it's going to
suck up his time and damage his psyche
musk's response to the novella of a
thread as he called it he said twitter
is way overdue for long-form tweets his
legion of die-hard fans might say
don't bet against him as for his critics
and there are quite a few musk tweeted i
hope that even my worst critics remain
on twitter because that is what free
speech means when he officially
confirmed he wanted to buy the app that
serves over 200 million daily users he
said in the sec filing twitter has
extraordinary potential adding i will
unlock it
at the core of any of elon musk's
ventures is a team of exceptional
engineers trying to change the world
whether you're in high school college or
you're professional who wants to brush
up on your stem skills brilliant is an
amazing tool for learning interactively
if you like to learn the fundamentals of
computer science or strengthen your
knowledge of core computer science
concepts the computer science
fundamentals course is perfect for you
and no coding is required and if you
want to dig deeper and learn more about
artificial intelligence their
introduction to neural networks course
is a great way to learn about data
processing machines by experimenting
hands-on there are no tests on brilliant
and if you ever get stuck you can read
the explanation for more brilliant is
free to try out if you head to the link
in my description or pin comment
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 of you to click my link will get 20
off the premium subscription which gives
you access to all of their offerings
thanks for watching for newsthink i'm
cindy palm
you